The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR STRANG: Alright.
So this is Lecture 15.
It's the last topic, today and
Friday, like just 15 and 16.
Trusses within Chapter 2.
The last topic we'll do
for discrete systems.
Then it's a lot of fun.
I wanted to say a few words
first about last night's exam.
Several words first.
Overall, I'm sure
it's going to be fine.
Ramis is grading the
first two problems,
he'll pass them to
Peter for the next two.
And I'll get them back.
I'm pretty sure
it'll be next week.
I felt it was a fair
exam, except I should
have done a better job in
helping you with the matrix A.
Especially in problem one.
I'm glad that hint was
there, the matrix A_0, that
goes with free-free, to sort
of say what kind of matrix
to be looking for.
And I thought I'd just repeat,
make the connections that I
should have made earlier.
So we all see the
point about these.
These A's and the
A transpose A's.
So if I take, for that
A_0, free-free one.
Everybody sees that this is--
And this connects of course
with our graphs.
Our graph is just this
simple graph with well
actually is that how
many, is it five nodes?
I guess there are five.
Because as it stands I have one,
two, three, four, five columns,
I've got five u's,
u_0 down to u_4.
And if I take A_0
transpose A_0, that
would be the free-free matrix.
What size would it be?
And what matrix would it be?
Just if we do that
multiplication,
this is a first
difference matrix.
When I do A_0
transpose A_0 I'll get
one of our second
difference matrices.
So it'll be one of
our special ones.
Which special one would it be?
B. It'll be the matrix B
that has both ends free.
And what size will it be?
I guess it'll be five by five.
That's right; that would be
five by four times A_0, which
is four by five.
So it'll be the five by five
matrix B. Can I call it B_5?
OK.
So that was there as a hint.
That isn't the correct
matrix for problem one
because problem one
was fixed-fixed.
Let's get there in two steps.
Suppose it's fixed-free.
So suppose I make u_0 equal 0.
So I ground the top node,
I support the top node--
Oh no, shall I do u_0?
Yeah.
I'll do u_0.
So that would
knock out this one.
If I say fix u_0, say,
at zero or whatever.
Now I've got, the next A, I
won't call it A_0 anymore.
So now four by four, now
if I do A transpose A,
which of our special
matrices am I going to get?
T. It'll be T. It'll be
the one that has the first,
the (1, 1) entry
will only be a one.
So that'll be the
fixed-free matrix.
It'll be of what size?
Four.
Now I've only got four
unknowns. u_1 to u_4.
OK, that still is not
what problem one is.
Problem one was fixed-fixed.
So as I did in the review,
that would knock out
both of these columns.
So this now is the matrix that I
was looking for in problem one,
and I wish I had emphasized
these steps in advance.
I apologize.
OK, so what fixed-fixed if,
without the C part in it.
Just focusing on the A, what
fixed-fixed matrix would I get?
Which one of our
guys would it be?
K of size three.
And while we're at it, what
would be the story, how would
I get one of these
circular ones, which
is sort of on our special list.
For Fourier it's the
really special guy.
So a circular one I'm going
to connect u_4 back to u_0.
So I'm going to put
these guys back in.
And what else would change, if
u_4 was connected back to u_0,
now I'm aiming for
this circulant.
What matrix A is going
to give me the circulant?
So again, these guys
are the A transpose A's.
This over here was the A, and
over here is the A transpose A.
And now I want to
fix A, and then
I want to see that A
transpose A. So suppose
I give you that graph, then.
Oops, I should have, well.
Just connect the whole guy.
So fifth node coming
back to the first.
So that's my circle of nodes.
That's a simple graph.
What's the A_circulant now?
So this would be the A
for the circulant case.
So it's got that back in.
That shouldn't be erased,
that shouldn't be erased.
And what else has it got?
If I ask you for the incidence
matrix, now I'm in Section 2.4,
like I've given
you a graph, or you
can think of masses and
springs in a circle.
So I've got five
masses, five springs.
What's my matrix A missing?
It needs another row.
We just put in another
edge, it needs another row.
That edge went from the last
node back to the first node.
So we've got a fifth row.
So you see, now it
really is circulant.
I would call this one
also a circulant matrix.
The diagonals are constant.
That's what I and MATLAB
and everybody else
would call a Toeplitz matrix,
and the command toeplitz
could create this.
That diagonal is constant.
The other diagonals
are constant.
But more than that,
what's additional
here in the circulant,
which is the thing that
makes Fourier happy?
The diagonal circles around.
That diagonal has only
got four entries in it,
but it circles around
sort of periodically
to its fifth entry.
So that's more than Toeplitz.
It's circulant because
it's coming around again.
This we'll see in the
discrete Fourier transform.
It's really all good stuff.
And now there is my a circulant.
And what would be my A
transpose circulant A_circulant?
What would be A transpose A if
I take that five by five matrix?
C. Finally I've created, so
I've already got B, I've got T,
I've got K, all those
three special guys.
And now the A transpose
A for this circulant,
so that's a first difference
matrix for a periodic problem.
And A transpose A will
be a second difference
matrix for a periodic
problem, C_5, I guess.
It'll be five.
OK.
I hope that brings together
what I, if I was on the ball,
I would have brought it
together before the quiz.
Can I just say a few words
about the quiz and grades?
They come out fine.
Really they do.
I've been doing
this a long time.
And just, enjoy October.
I'm sorry to give
you any exam at all,
but it's a chance for you yeah,
I'm working on this stuff.
I'm learning it.
Everybody didn't
learn it first time.
I don't learn it
first time, every time
I teach the course I
learn something more.
And if you're learning from this
course then I'm totally happy.
And I believe that's the case.
So I am entirely happy.
And I hope the quiz,
some points of it
I wish I'd prepared better.
But I feel pretty good about it.
I feel good about
it, let me just say.
So, and I'm happy to have any
comments, email or in person.
But allow me to go
forward with trusses.
However, I'm ready
always for a comment.
Yeah.
OK.
Anyway, enjoy trusses.
Enjoy life.
Yeah.
And this should have been
in the book, this page.
So if it wasn't too late
I would paste it in.
Because this connects
A transpose A
to special matrices, in
the way I had in my mind,
but I didn't put it on
the board until just now.
OK, so I'll cover that up
and ready to go with trusses.
OK.
So trusses, we want
to know what's up.
We want to get the setup right.
Once we get the setup we'll
know we're looking for.
OK, so a truss is a bunch of
elastic bars with pin joints
connecting them.
Now, what do I mean
by a pin joint?
I mean that stretching
the bars takes force.
Turning around the pin
joint doesn't take force.
So the pin just lets
them turn, so we'll
have forces in those bars.
So it's like masses and springs.
Exactly like masses and springs.
But yet we have a 2-D problem.
So it's a two
dimensional problem
with masses and springs.
And we could certainly
have a 3-D truss,
but 2-D makes all
the important points.
And then I can count the bars.
One, two, three, four, five.
And I can count the nodes.
There happen to be five here.
But now comes the moment.
I have to tell you,
what are the unknowns?
What are the u's.
Because of course,
you know that I'm
going to go from u's to
e's to w's, to forces, f.
And you know that a matrix
A is going to do that.
A matrix C is going to do that.
A matrix A transpose
is going to do that.
You're all ready, we need
to know what's the setup.
What are these matrices.
OK, and how many-- So
let me explain the setup.
Typical node, node one. we
have forces in these bars,
so that node one
could have a force.
We're in the plane.
So we have a horizontal
force and a vertical force.
Together, that would
give, produces a force
in any direction whatever.
So this is the key point.
That there is a horizontal
force. f horizontal one.
The one being the
force on node one.
But there's also
a vertical force.
And let me take
horizontal to the right,
positive to the right.
Vertical positive upwards.
Just to have a convention.
So how many f's have I got?
Well, the point is I
now have two per node.
That's the difference.
I have two per node, two forces.
And I have two
displacements per node.
Because that point under,
there will be more forces.
Some maybe pulling
this way, whatever.
Maybe let's look at node two.
So node two could have a
couple of forces on it.
f h two, and f v two.
And it moves like
the other nodes.
So now I'm introducing
the unknowns. u
is the movement. u,
again horizontal,
and again, now we're
talking about node two.
And it moves up.
Or doesn't, or moves down.
But that's an unknown.
u, a displacement,
a vertical displacement
of node two.
Do you see the setup?
Two forces per node.
Two displacements per node.
So that's like, the number
of unknown is like doubled.
Like, doubled, and that produces
an interesting situation.
I've marked supports here.
So let's just speak
about supports.
So what's happening
at the supports?
At the support
there's no movement.
The whole-- That
point is pinned.
So this is telling me
that u horizontal five
is zero and u vertical,
sorry that was four
and it'll be the same for
five. u vertical five is zero.
It's like grounding a node
in the electrical case.
We just see this
pattern over and over.
And we want to see OK, what
does it look like for trusses?
So here's a support
that fixes those.
So those are not unknowns.
And similarly, they're
not unknowns there.
Still saying five
when I mean four.
So those are boundary
conditions, n conditions,
whatever.
And similarly here.
So how many unknowns are there?
Now look at this picture, how
many unknown displacements
are there in this truss?
Six.
Six, right?
Two here, two here, two
here and none there.
So the number of
actual unknowns is six.
My idea would be that it's
twice the number of nodes
minus the number of fixed
things, reaction, whatever.
That R would be
four in this case.
I've got two fixed here
and two fixed here,
so this would be two times five.
Ten possible
displacements but R counts
the number of fixed
displacements, four,
and leaves us with six.
OK.
So my matrix A will now
be, it's always m by n.
My matrix A will be five by six.
OK.
Now you're going to ask
what is that matrix.
But let me hold that
off for a little moment.
I want to just see
its shape first.
So you could now do this
for a large truss, right?
You count the bars, and
you could count the nodes.
And then you could count the
unknown displacements, u.
So there are six u's here.
And there are five e's.
And there are five bar forces.
And there are six equilibrium,
balance, force balances.
Six, six for the node count,
for the unknowns count,
five, five for the bars count.
OK, now here's a point
about this particular truss.
It's not safe to get on it.
Right?
And I want to say
why is it not safe.
So this is a feature that comes
into the truss question that
makes it a little new
and more interesting.
A little twist compared
to the previous examples.
That bar, that truss,
I wouldn't stand on it.
Now, why not?
Well, purely for
linear algebra reasons.
Of course.
The matrix A is five by six.
So now what do we know about
a matrix that's five by six?
So A is five by six.
Five rows, as always the m;
six columns, because now we
have six unknowns.
And what do I know about
any five by six matrix?
I want to ask about
the equation Au=0.
So I want to ask about it
in linear algebra language
and then I want to ask about
it in physical language.
And the beauty is the thing
that makes trusses sort of fun
is, these matrices, A,
get pretty big fast.
Because when I put
a few more nodes on,
the book has a picture
of a sort of treehouse.
Then A is growing.
And I don't, all the time,
write down the matrix A.
I haven't written it down here.
What I've written
down is just its size,
because that's enough to tell
us something about this set
of equations Au=0.
What's the story on Au=0?
Well of course it
has the solution u=0.
Nothing moving.
If I have no displacement,
if the u's are all zero,
then I have no stretching.
The e's are stretching.
Elongation, as before.
How far does the bar stretch?
OK.
So if I have zero
u's and zero e's.
But, what other possibility
am I going to have here?
I'm going to have
probably one solution
to this system that isn't zero.
I'm probably going to have one
set of displacements u, look
what's happening here.
This is Au is the e.
So I'm going to have at least
one and probably in this case
it will be one, there will
be one, the neat word for it
is a mechanism.
And what does that mean?
A mechanism is a
solution to Au=0.
So that, a mechanism is
a movement of the bar.
So it's going to be non-zero.
The bars are going
to move a little.
Sorry, the nodes are
going to move a little.
The nodes will
move a little bit.
In this u, because
it isn't zero.
But the bars won't stretch.
So that tells us we've
got instability here.
If there's a solution
to that, that's
always telling us that A
transpose A is singular.
So let me just put
that A transpose A --
or A transpose C A, C couldn't
save it -- will be singular.
It's just like our free-free
thing in being singular,
but the picture doesn't
look free-free, does it?
It's got supports in here,
just not good enough.
And I believe that if
you look at this truss,
you could describe,
you could tell me,
and you could draw, a movement
of that truss in which
there is displacement
but no stretching.
Let me ask you how to draw that.
And I believe--
Everybody understood,
why was there a solution?
It was because we
have six unknowns
and we only have five equations.
So this was five equations.
Any time you have five
equations with a zero
on the right-hand side,
so five homogeneous
equations, whatever you
want to say when that's zero
on the right and six unknowns.
Six u's.
Then you're going
to have solution.
You can't help it.
You've got that many
degrees of freedom,
you've only got that
many constraints, there's
going to be solution.
OK, tell me how to draw that.
Let me put in the truss now.
What's the solution?
So this is the fun part
in a particular example
at the start.
How could that move
without stretching bars?
Let me see.
What could happen?
What do you mean now,
who's going to move where?
What's the movement here?
And I want to draw
it over there.
So you give the answer
by drawing it as well
as by telling me
the six unknown u's.
So what can happen
at this thing?
So you're going to say the
truss could, these bars could,
turn a little?
And notice that word a little.
We're talking
small displacement,
small stretches
all the time here.
I'll show you why
we're always making
that linearity assumption,
or small assumption.
OK, those move a little.
And what happens to that
triangle at the top?
It sort of just
moves along, right?
So the picture you
would draw would
be that you started there.
And it moved along
a little, I'll
make it a larger displacement
than I really have in mind.
These guys of course are here.
So they come out and
the rest of the truss,
the top of the truss,
just kind of goes with it.
Goes with the flow.
That would be the answer
that I would be looking for,
to draw the mechanism.
That would show it.
And if I wanted to
write down the u that
goes with it, what would it be?
Let me again number these
guys; this is one, two,
and this is three.
So what are the displacements
of nodes one, two, and three?
I'll always write u_1
horizontal before vertical.
Can we make an agreement?
So I want to know about
the horizontal movement
then the vertical
movement of node one,
then node two, then node three.
So I'll have six numbers there.
And what could I put in
for those six numbers?
So the horizontal, let me
suppose that that first guy,
I'll put a one.
Really that's a bigger
number than I should put,
but it's a convenient number.
So I'll just take it to be
one even though I really
have in mind-- Let's say
that's one angstrom, or one
tiny little person.
OK, so what about the rest?
What's the vertical-- Oh yeah,
this is a key point here,
what's the vertical movement?
This movement to
me is horizontal.
I'm going to say that the
vertical moment is zero.
Of node one, just moves over.
And node two does the same.
And node three does the same.
So that's my solution.
[1, 0, 1,  0, 1, 0].
That's a simple movement, a
simple set of displacements,
think most to the right.
I have not written
down the matrix A,
but probably won't even
do it until next time.
But you will see that
when we do the matrix A
for this particular truss
will have this particular u
as a mechanism.
In linear algebra, u is in
the null space of A. Au=0,
that's all that means.
OK, do you see more
or less what's up?
But now there's one little
thing that may be bothering you.
Which is what?
If I come back to the
zero, zero, zero there,
you could correctly
say wait a minute,
if those bars didn't
stretch, if they just
rotated as you
told me to do, then
this was mostly across but
a little bit down, right?
And I'm saying no.
I'm saying zero.
OK, how do I get away with that?
So I'm saying in
18.085 it's a zero.
And why?
So this is like a little
time-out just to focus in on,
let me focus in on node two.
So here's the bottom
node four, so it
used to be vertical up to two.
This was node two and
this was number four.
And then it rotated
a little, to there.
To this position.
So it went, if this
angle was, let's say,
theta, then what is
that actual position?
So let's say this was, let's
say the bar had length one.
This is the origin, (0, 0).
This is the point
(0, 1) above it, OK?
And now, that's before it moved.
Then it moved a little bit.
It moved to an angle theta.
What's the position of that bar?
Of that node?
What's the new
position of the node,
and then we'll look
at the difference
and we'll see the movement
u, the displacement.
So how far did it move?
What's the x-coordinate?
How far did it go across?
If I put in that
line you'll know.
So the movement across
was, sin(theta)?
Good. sin(theta).
And the movement down, well,
yes, so let's find its position
and then we'll take
the difference.
So what's the vertical
new position for that guy?
It moved by, it moved
across by sin(theta).
And down by 1-cos(theta).
Are you agreed with that?
Because here is cosine
theta, right there.
And here's the little
bit it moved down.
OK.
So these are exactly correct.
Yeah this is in the position
of sin(theta), cos(theta),
and the difference
was the 1-cos(theta).
OK, so now here
comes the key point.
Approximately, sin(theta)
is approximately,
if theta is small and now here
comes the smallness, sin(theta)
is approximately
theta. sin(theta)'s
approximately theta.
And 1-cos(theta) is
approximately what?
Now, this is the
important point.
So theta is like the first term.
If I expand, I
mean, the exact term
would be theta minus theta
cubed over six, dot dot dot.
But I'm only keeping that term.
And 1-cos(theta), now what's
the formula for cos(theta)?
This is like worth,
just should--
It's a one, because of
course cos(0) is one,
and then you subtract what?
Theta squared over two.
And so on.
And then plus theta fourth
over 24 or whatever.
OK, so the ones
cancel as we expect.
And I'm getting theta
squared over two.
And this, here was theta
to the first power.
Theta cubed was, we didn't care.
And we don't care
about theta squared.
So that's why it's zero.
Because it's a second
order movement.
If theta is small, as I'm going
to assume, small displacement,
theta squared would, if
I allowed theta squared
and cos(theta) in here, I'd
have a non-linear problem.
And I don't want that.
And I don't need it.
I mean, finite elements,
structures, bridges, whatever.
Your first hope and
expectation and calculation
is small theta, linear problem.
So to a linear person
theta squared is zero.
That's why those guys are zero.
OK, so that's an
assumption we'll often see,
so it kind of was.
There are two kinds
of non-linearities
in structures and elasticity.
One would be to allow this
geometric non-linearity.
Thetas, large
displacements, theta large
enough so that you can't
neglect theta squared.
That's a tough one.
If you allow geometric
non-linearity in,
as finite element
codes have to do.
If you-- ABAQUS is a code
that does major finite element
calculations, nonlinear ones.
I mean they, at the
beginning they were studying
what happens, what are
the stresses on cables
under the Atlantic.
I mean, those are
fascinating problems.
Or I mention car crashes.
I mean, car crashes,
the geometry changes,
you have big displacements.
But we're talking here about
linear small displacement
cases.
OK, so don't forget that part.
That when the truss
gets more complicated,
the principle stays the same.
That we distinguish between
the thetas that matter
and the theta
squareds that don't.
OK, so now what?
Now I guess I'm
ready to complete
this picture a little more.
OK.
So let me, so we've understood
what's the idea of a mechanism.
Oh, how could I
prevent a mechanism?
In other words, if I
stood on this truss,
the slightest bit of wind
would crash it down, right?
So that's unstable.
That's an unstable truss.
How could I make it stable?
I mean if you were designing
this thing, what would you do?
Add another edge.
You'd stick in another bar.
Maybe stick in a bar there.
What would happen now?
Would it now be stable?
You'd have to answer
that question.
You couldn't just put
in bars, whatever.
You want to put bars
that do the job.
OK, now how many bars?
We've now got six bars.
So m is now up to six.
The matrix A is six by six now,
whatever that matrix may be.
We have six bars,
six displacements.
We can hope that we now
have a six by six, well,
we do have a six by six
matrix, whatever it looks like.
And we can hope that
it's not singular.
We can hope it's
invertible, we can hope
that that mechanism is killed.
And you see it is killed.
The six by six, that
truss is now stable.
No mechanism there, right?
Again I haven't written
down the matrix,
but I'm really calling for
engineering intuition here.
That this truss is now
stable, and of course I
can make it even more stable
by adding a seventh edge.
A seventh bar.
So when it was six I had square
matrices, A transpose and then
C and then A would
have been square.
Now I've got seven bars and, so
now I've put in a seventh guy.
m is now up to seven.
My matrix a would
now be seven by six.
Mechanism will be
gone because I've
now got, what, seven equations.
Same six u's.
So we begin to get a feel of,
are there solutions or not?
What I'm saying is, I can't
tell just from the count
that A is not singular.
I could have a lot of bars
and still be unstable.
Invent a truss for me.
Just because, how could you
invent a truss that had, maybe
it has seven bars.
With those seven bars, those
diagonal guys, that did it.
That made it stable.
Our eye tells us that before
we do any linear algebra.
Tell me a seven by-- A thing.
Well, yeah.
OK, so here would be, shall
we support both of these?
I'll start out the same, OK.
Now, yeah, how could I, let's
see, I've haven't prepared.
How could I get a
whole lot of bars.
I might not get seven by
six exactly, but how could
I have plenty of bars
and still unstable?
Well, suppose I do this.
Oh yeah, that's a good example.
That's not stable, right?
OK.
Every let's practice
with that one.
That's just my idea,
and problems in the book
just ask you to practice
with things like that.
Tell me the count, first.
What is m, the number of bars?
Six.
What is n, the number
of unknowns, little n,
the number of unknowns?
What's the shape
of my matrix here?
A is, it's got six bars
and how many unknowns?
Eight.
Eight, right?
Two here, two, two, two.
None here.
Six by eight.
OK.
And how many mechanisms
am I now expecting?
Probably two.
Probably two, there would be
two independent mechanisms here.
Can you tell me
what they look like?
Draw them.
What would they look like?
What would be two different
things that could happen,
could go wrong with that truss?
You see it, right?
This could turn.
As in our example with the
top part moving with it.
Or, a second one possibility
would be the top part goes.
And the bottom part stays.
Or any combination.
So the whole thing
could go like that.
That would be one.
But that wouldn't be
the only one, of course.
So in other words, we have
a two-dimensional space
of mechanisms and you could
give me two different,
and there are not just two
guys, all their combinations
are there.
So this would have
two mechanisms.
Two mechanisms.
And I could put in
bars, of course,
that would try to save it.
Well, how many bars, what's
the minimum number of bars
I absolutely need to make
this thing stable again?
Two.
Well, now suppose I
put in these two bars.
Right?
I've got enough bars, I've
got an eight by eight matrix,
but I haven't saved it.
Right?
Because it still
has that mechanism.
So you can't assume that
because the count is right
you've avoided mechanisms
because in that example you
haven't.
OK, so that would be a case
of square eight by eight,
but not good.
So as soon as I say
there's a solution to Au=0,
I know that A transpose
A will be singular.
And unstable.
OK, before I go to the framework
let's just do one more thing.
Suppose I take
away the supports.
All right, let me put
in some bars, though.
I'll put in some bars.
OK, plenty of bars.
Want another one?
OK, how many bars have I got?
Lots, right?
OK, now the matrix A, what
do you think about this?
Are there solutions?
You haven't even seen
the matrix A, of course,
but you've seen the truss,
that's what matters.
How many solutions, are
there solutions to Au=0?
Are there ways that this truss
could move without stretching?
And what are they, and
how many are there?
And what name should we use?
OK, what are they?
How could that move
without stretching?
Well, it's got no
supports at all.
It's just free out
there in space.
So it could move.
How many ways could it move?
Three.
It could move, everybody
could move this way.
All ones on the horizontal guys.
Everybody could move
this way, all six
ones on the vertical guys,
it'll be 12 unknowns here.
And it could also rotate,
what would be the rotation?
I'm not talking
about this rotation.
This could not happen.
What could happen?
What rotation could happen here?
For this, there's a
third rigid motion.
Translation, translation,
and rotation around,
well take this
one as an example.
The whole thing could
swing around this.
That would be a motion.
Well now you're
going to say well,
why didn't I swing
it around that one?
And of course it could.
But what would be the deal?
It would have to be, there
are only three rigid motions,
right, up and around.
So if you give me another
one, like, around this one,
then somehow it had to be
a combination of those.
I don't even want to think
what combination it is.
But there are three
rigid motions.
So I sort of distinguish
mechanisms, this word
mechanism.
So that's where
the truss deforms.
In these-- And rigid motions,
so I'll say plus, possibly.
Plus rigid motions,
and rigid motions
would be, you know, it
doesn't deform internally,
the whole thing moves.
And this is of
course what we get
in the case of not
enough supports.
And this is what we get in
the case of not enough bars.
Yeah.
So maybe it's worth
separating those two.
In the examples we do, we'll
usually put in enough supports
to kill the rigid motions.
And then the question would
be are there some mechanisms.
OK.
Now, I have to start
on what this is.
Well it'll be just
a very quick start.
So what I'll do at the
beginning of Friday,
so Friday's the other
lecture on this topic.
And then the homework will
ask you to do some trusses
in this section.
It's probably Section
2 point something.
2.7, maybe.
What's the matrix C?
Last second question, what's
the matrix C, what size is it?
What size is the matrix C
for our original problem?
Or no.
What size is C, is C
involving, if I know
these numbers, what size is C?
Five by five. m by m, right?
C is the diagonal matrix,
one entry for each bar,
C is just C. It has a c_1,
c_2, c_3, and this w=Ce,
it's just Hooke's
Law on each bar.
So, simple.
It gets there in the
middle, just the way that C
in the first exam problem
popped in, and other C's.
That gets there in the middle.
But it's very,
extremely, simple.
OK, so the real attention
is on A, as usual.
And that will come
Friday morning.